so we're told that f of X is equal to
the infinite series we're going from N
equals one to infinity of n plus 1 over
4 to the n plus 1 times X to the N and
what we want to figure out is what is
the definite integral from 0 to 1 of
this f of X and like always if you feel
inspired I encourage you to feel
inspired pause the video and see if you
could work through this on your own or
at any time while I'm working through it
pause it and try to keep on going all
right well let's just rewrite this a
little bit this is going to be the same
thing as the integral from 0 to 1 f of X
is this is this series so I could write
the sum from N equals 1 to infinity of n
plus 1 over 4 to the n plus 1 times X to
the N and now what I'm about to do might
be the thing that might be new to some
of you but this is essentially we're
taking a definite integral of a sum of
terms and that's the same thing as
taking the sum of a bunch of definite
integrals let me make that clear so if I
had a let's say this is a definite
integral 0 to 1 and let's say I had a
bunch of terms here I could even call
them functions let's say it was G of X
plus h of X and I just kept going on and
on and on DX well this is the same thing
as the sum of the integrals as the
integral from 0 to 1 of G of X G of X DX
plus the integral from 0 to 1 H of X DX
plus and we go on and on and on forever
however many of these terms are this
comes straight out of our integration
properties so we can do the exact same
thing here although we'll just do it
with the Sigma notation this is going to
be equal to this is going to be equal to
the sum from N equals 1 to infinity of
the integral the definite integral of
each of these terms so I'm going to
write it like this so of the integral
from 0 to 1 of n plus 1 over 4 to the n
plus 1 power times X to the N
then it is DX so once again now we're
taking the sum of each of these terms so
let's evaluate let's evaluate this
business right over here so that is
going to I'll just keep writing it out
this is going to be equal to the sum
from N equals one to infinity and then
the stuff that I just underlined in
orange this is going to be let's see we
take the antiderivative here we are
going to get to X to the n plus one and
we're going to divide by n plus one so
we have this original n plus 1 over 4 to
the n plus 1 and and that's just a
constant when we think in terms of X for
any one of these terms and then here
we'd want to increment the exponent and
then divide by the incremented exponent
this just comes out of hi I often call
it the inverse pot or the the anti power
rule or reversing the power rule so it's
X to the n plus 1 over n plus 1 I just
took the antiderivative now we're going
to go from 0 to 1 for each of these
terms and before we do that we can
simplify we have an N plus 1 we have an
N plus 1 and so we can rewrite all of
this this is going to be the same thing
we're going to take the sum from N
equals 1 to infinity and this is going
to be what we have in here when X is
equal to 1 it is 1 we could write 1 to
the n plus 1 over 4 to the n plus 1
actually yeah why don't I write it that
way 1 over 1 to the n plus 1 over 4 to
the n plus 1 minus 0 to the n plus 1
over 4 to the n plus 1 so we're not
going to even have to write that I could
write 0 to the n plus 1 over 4 to the n
plus 1 but this is clearly just 0 and
then this and this is starting to get
nice and simple now this is going to be
the same thing this is equal to the sum
from N equals 1 to infinity we almost
are going to get to our drum roll of 1/4
to the n plus 1 now you might
immediately recognize this this is an
finit geometric series what is the first
term here well the first term first
first term is well when n is equal to
when n is equal to 1 the first term here
is 1/4 to the second power did I do that
right
yeah when n is equal to 1 it's going to
be so this is going to be 1/4 to the 2nd
power which is equal to 1 over 16 so
that's our first term and then our
common ratio common common ratio here
well that's going to be well we're going
to ever we're going to keep multiplying
by 1/4 so our common ratio here is 1/4
and so for an infinite geometric series
this is it's our common ratio the well
is less than or it's it's its absolute
value is less than 1 we know that this
is going to converge and it's going to
converge to the value our first term 1
over 16 divided by 1 minus the common
ratio 1 minus 1/4 so this is 3/4 so it's
equal to 1 over 16 times 4 over 3 so 1
for this is going to be equal to 1/12
and we're done and this seemed really
daunting at first but we just said to
realize okay in an integral of a sum
even an infinite sum well that's going
to be the sum of these infinite
integrals we take the antiderivative of
these infinite integrals which we were
able to do which is kind of a cool thing
one of the powers of symbolic
mathematics and then we realize oh we
just have a we have an infinite
geometric series which we know how to
find the sum of and we're done